hey let's go breasts my name is goat
said got updated there's a new map cold
before outbreak hey
oh my hey a goat zombie outbreak mice
one near people to infect them okay
start a zombie outbreak hi friend I love
you
now you're a zippy I still love you
though
lick you three do that oh jesus [ __ ]
christ I'm really confused but
intriguing at the same time I will is
craft a weapon drag stuff and then lick
they okay today I will take this gumball
machine and we created
a thing whoa
a weapon Wow Wow it's shouting killed
three Sammy's
it makes so much sense PvP experience
it's just what I wanted
thanks goat see know what you sure it
would be a shame if NSYNC oh god [ __ ]
patient zero
hey box appear on walls hey where you
going
that's right [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
happening
goat see uh this is goat I mean don't
die now oh oh no no no no no this is not
what I want it that's setup a [ __ ] I'm
fine I'm fine how's it going everyone
I'm goatee where the [ __ ] am I nice hat
bruh
okay I really need to get this outbreak
started what is happening Jesus Christ
calm down four out of five baby ah this
code is some fire and we did it half at
that's a sweeping I like that man's
balls why are they hitting me I thought
zombies only at each other
I ride his bicycle I want to read math
bad damn it
excuse me can't you see I'm [ __ ]
riding a bicycle here oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] gonna go ride a damn bike this
is sick jump
nailed it ha why is this turning me on
let's go to the in bed off for [ __ ]
sake can't you see I'm goning here stop
do you ever feel like you are a goat
zipping through the win aah
I just gotta ignite yeah baby
a goat simulator act like a goat now
that's just ridiculous
aah I got [ __ ] wrecked fortune teller
yes hello there beautiful now tell me
everything
okay thank you for telling me that
stupid good [ __ ] did you say
oh---but is that a cannon yes thank you
I will go inside you
baby
this is how go to swim it's written if
you don't believe me just check with the
video it's true Barriss oh yeah riding
with my top down with my stereo just get
my hood on I'm just doing my thing uh uh
Oh God ha ha
I'm just doing my eggs [ __ ] sake what
is this what the [ __ ] is going on
is this even a game don't you live with
that Marik
come here your [ __ ] come here now be
in the circus look at this holy man look
at that [ __ ]
all right breasts it looks like we we
succeeded with it by doing absolutely
nothing today I look forward to play
more live it like if you want to see
more and let me know click here for more
similar videos rose thinking so much for
watching I will see you in the next one
as always stay awesome bros i'm getting
XP just standing on dead goats this is a
great game i have great legs
I have great walking style gotta give it
to myself let's try out our abilities we
have number one which does looks like a
pizza